[موسيقى]
على خلفيه التلويح بتدخل عسكري ضد قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر مالي وبوركينا فاسو
تحذران من ان اي محاوله للتدخل تعتبر
عدوانا عليهما في وقت اعلنت فيه دول غربيه
انها ستبدا اليوم اجلاء راعياها
والمواطنين الاوروبيين الراغبين في
المغادره
موجه من الفيضانات تشهدها الصين ادت الى
مصرع اكثر من عشره اشخاص وفقدان العشرات
كما تم اجلاء اكثر من 100 الف
مرتاء اكثر من 200 رحله جويه في حين اجلت
اليابان مئات الالاف من السكان تحسبا
لاعصار خانون
الجزيره تندد بمواصله اعتقال الصحفيين
ربيع الشيخ وبهاء ابراهيم بصوره غير
قانونيه وتحمل السلطات المصريه المسؤوليه
الكامله عن سلامتهما كما اعربت خلال وقفه
تضامنيه عن قلقها ازاء ظروف احتجازهما
ودعت المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات الدوليه
للضغط من اجل الافراج الفوري عنهما الى
اللقاء